les policiers étaient nombreux près du
siège du parti politique d'opposition
parnas ce les journalistes devaient
montrer patte blanche
l'édifice avait été la cible de nombreux
appels à la bombe ces derniers jours il
y à shinko président un mouvement a fait
solidarnost avec boris nemtsov au moment
de son assassinat en février dernier il
n'a jamais cru que les auteurs présumés
arrêtés à l'époque avait agi seul
le principal accusé à ould daddah yav
était un officier de haut rang de
l'armée personnel du dictateur
tchétchène ramzan kadyrov
il ay ay ay chine a préparé un rapport
où il décrit kadyrov
la protégée de vladimir poutine comme
une menace pour la russie un homme
corrompu et sans pitié
pendant la présentation du rapport un
jeune homme lançait des copies de
dollars américains sur yashin les médias
officiels tout comme ramzan kadyrov
accuse régulièrement l'opposition d'être
financé par les etats-unis les
interruptions se sont multipliées les
policiers venant à plusieurs reprises
demandé aux journalistes de quitter la
salle
prétextant un appel à la bombe yashin
répété aux policiers que ce n'était
qu'une des nombreuses menaces reçues
récemment les policiers revenaient à la
charge
finalement iasi avait le temps de dire
gamme style the beast je suis persuadé
que c'est kadyrov qui est derrière
l'assassinât de mon ami nemtsov et je
veux que kadyrov soit tu du responsable
de ce meurtre
tout le monde était forcé de partir et
la foule de journalistes se retrouvait
dans la rue entourés de policiers
voilà c'est le genre de choses qui se
produisent à moscou près d'un an après
l'assassinât de boris nemtsov toujours
difficile toujours risqué d'être dans
l'opposition
ici en russie
d'autres membres de l'opposition ont été
harcelés récemment mais qu'at elle quasi
à neuf étaient attaquées entarté en fait
9 février dernier à moscou par une
dizaine d'hommes parlant tchétchènes qui
le menaçait fin janvier
ramzan kadyrov publié une vidéo où le
même case ya neuf étaient clairement
pris comme cible de tireurs
il y décrivait les représentants de
l'opposition comme des ennemis du peuple
les groupes d'opposition prévoient
manifester à moscou samedi à la mémoire
de nude seul comme il l'avait fait il y
a un an
et si raymond saclay radio canada à
moscou